Hi, I'm Staci Greenbaum.
I'm the costume designer
for Broad City.
I have a couple
of favorite moments.
One really,
really amazing moment
this season so far
is Ilana in the Matrix.
I want a look that says,
"I am the internet.
I am the Matrix.
I am the future
and the future is female,
as well as paperless."
I've been waiting for this
since 1999.
Rather than covering Ilana up,
we created this really
hilarious trench-back cape,
so that it gave her
a lot of movement.
We made her this really
fantastic choker
that is a myriad of different
computer cords,
which was just a riot, along
with her really micro glasses.
That's right.
This is my favorite sweatshirt.
It's this sweatshirt.
This is Abbi's real,
original sweatshirt from MICA.
It's been washed
a hundred thousand times.
It's actually a vintage
sweatshirt
with like the perfect amount
of wear, so.
MICA? I don't want this shit.
I went to RISD.
This actually is
my assistant designer, Val's,
Mom's stress from the 80s,
which looked unbelievable
on Ilana.
I farted and it went up my dress
and up my nose,
and then it dissipated.
Paired beautifully
with these earrings that we made
so that she could just be
more of who she is.
I saw them and I thought of you.
Why? Just kidding.
These costumes
are best shown together.
For Abbi,
we have this really colorful,
playful shirt and jeans.
If you recall back to the pilot,
Ilana ends that episode
wearing a shirt that says,
"I love you, Weezy,"
or not exactly those words,
but pretty close.
We decided we would
bring it back
with some electrical tape
on this costume.
It's just a really fun moment.
I love how colorful
and playful they are.
Old are y'all, anyway?
I can't tell
because those outfits
aren't matching the faces.
Next.